نعم ازدهار بوتين اليوم الرئيس الروسي
تحدث عن معطيات عده اولها السياقه العام
لهذه الحرب للهجوم المضاد اكد ان الغرب
يستخدم اوكرانيا لزعزعه الاوضاع في روسيا
وانما يجري حاليا في هذه المرحله بالتحديد
هو نزع سلاح اوكرانيا تدريجيا وقال انه في
المستقبل القريب ان صناعه الدفاع في
اوكرانيا ستنتهي تحدث بطبيعه الحال عن
الهجوم المضاد بشكل واسع وقال ان اوكرانيا
حاليا تستخدم الاحتياطيات الاستراتيجيه
وان هذا الهجوم لم يحقق مراده هو ان هناك
خسائر فادحه بنسبه للقوات الاوكرانيه
وصفها بانها تقترب من الكارثه في ميزان
الخسائر تحدث بوتين انه في خلال هذا
الهجوم خسرت اوكرانيا اكثر من 160 دبابه
واكثر من 360 مدرعه فقدت وفق بوت بالمائه
من حجم المعدات التي تم تسليمها من الخارج
وهو ايضا اعترف بالخسائر التي منيت بها
روسيا في هذه الحرب قال انها خسرت فقط 54
دبابه ويمكن استعاده بعضها وقال ان
الخسائر البشريه متقاربه بشكل كبير ايضا
تطرق الى موضوع الحدود والمناطق الحدوديه
التي تم استهدافها في الايام الماضيه
اخرها كان كورسك صبيحه اليوم التي تتعرض
لهجمات متكرره قال واكد ان القوات
الاوكرانيه لا تتواجد في مقاطعه بالغرد
الحدوديه وقال انه هناك ضروره لتعزيز
الحدود الروسيه وتحدث عن تفصيل اساسي
مرتبط بالدفاعات الجويه وتطوير هذه
الدفاعات لحتى تصبح قادره على رصد والتصدي
للمسيارات في موضوع اكد ان القوات
الاوكرانيه هي من فجرت هذا السد لان هذا
الامر ليس من مصلحه روسيا وعلى العكس
لديه عواقب كبيره مرتبطه بالمناطق التي
تسيطر عليها روسيا